The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORENZO ROSASCO:
If you remember,
we did the local
method bias-variance.
Then we passed to global
regularization methods-- least
squares, linear least
squares, kernel least squares,
computations modeling.
And that's where we were at.
And then we moved on
and started to think
about more intractable
model, and we
were starting to think of the
problem of variable selection,
OK?
And the way we posed it is
that, yeah, that you are going
to consider a linear model.
And I use the weights
associated to each variable
as the strength of the
corresponding variable
that you can view
as measurements.
And your game is
not only to build
good predictional
measurements, but also
to tell which measurements
are interesting, OK?
And so here, the term
"relevant variable"
is going to be related to the
productivity, the contribution
to the productivity of the
corresponding function, OK?
So that's how we measure
relevance of a variable.
So we looked at the funny name.
And then we kind of
agreed that somewhat it
seems that there is a
default approach, which
is basically based on trying
all possible subsets, OK?
So this is also called
best subset selection.
Variable selection is
also sometimes called
best subset selection.
And this gives you a feeling
that what you should do
is try all possible subsets
and check the one which
is best with respect to your
data, which, again, would
be like a trade-off between
how well you fit the data
and how many variables
you have, OK?
And what I told you last
was you could actually
see that this trying
all possible subsets
is related to a form
of regularization,
where it looks very
similar to the one
we saw until a minute ago.
The main difference
here, I put fw,
but fw is just the
usual linear function.
The only difference
is that here,
rather than the square
norm, we put this functional
that is called the
0 norm, which if,
as a functional,
that given a vector
returns the number of
entries in the vector which
are different from 0, OK?
It turns out that if you
were to minimize this,
you are solving the best
subset selection problem.
Issue here is that--
another manifestation
of the complexity of
the problem is the fact
that this functional
here is non-convex.
So there is no
polynomial algorithm
to actually find a solution.
Come to my mind that
somebody made the comment
during the break.
Notice that here I'm
a bit passing quickly
over a refinement of the
question of best subset
selection, which is
related to, is there
a unique subset which is good?
Is there more than one?
And if there's more than one,
which one should I pick, OK?
In practice, these
questions arise immediately
because if you have
two measurements that
are very correlated,
or even more,
if they're perfectly
correlated, if you just
build the measurements,
you might build out
of two measurements, a
third measurement, which
is completely just a linear
combination of the first two.
So at that point, what
would you want to do?
Do you want to keep
the minimum number
of variables, the biggest
possible number of variables?
And you have to decide,
because all these variables
are, to some extent,
completely dependent, OK?
So for now, we just
keep to the case
where we don't really
worry about this, OK?
We just say, among the good
ones, we want to pick one.
A harder question would
be pick all of them
or pick one of them.
And if you wanted to pick one
of them, you have to tell me
which one you want, according
to which criterion, OK?
So the problem we're concerned
with now is one of, OK, now
that we know that we
might want to do this,
how can you do it in
an approximate way that
will be good enough, and what
does it mean, good enough?
So the simplest
way, again, we can
try to think about
it together, is
kind of a greedy version of
the brute force approach.
So the brute force
approach was start
from all single variables,
then all couples,
then all triplets, and
blah, blah, blah, blah, OK?
And this doesn't
work computationally.
So just to wake
up, I don't know,
how could you
twist this approach
to make it approximate, but
computationally feasible?
Let's keep the same spirit.
So let's start from few, and
then let's try to add more.
So the general
idea is I pick one.
And once I pick one, I
pick another one, just
keeping the one
I already picked.
And then I pick another one,
and then I pick another one,
and then I pick another one.
So this, of course, will
not be the exhaustive search
I've done before.
It's probably doable.
There is a bunch of
different ways you can do it.
And you can hopefully--
you can hope that
under some condition
you might be able to prove
that it's not too far
away from the brute
force approach, at least
under some condition.
And this is kind of what
we would want to do, OK?
So we will have a
notion of residual.
At the first
iteration, the residual
will be just the output.
So just think of
the first iteration.
You get the output vectors,
and you want to explain it.
You want to predict it well, OK?
So what you do is that you first
check the one variable that
gives you the best
prediction of this guy,
and then you compute
the prediction.
Then what you want to
do at the next round,
you want to discount what
you have already explained.
And what you do is
that basically you
take the actual output
minus your prediction,
and you find the residual.
And then you try
to explain that.
That's what's left
to explain, OK?
So now you check
for the variables
that best explain
this remaining bit.
Then you add this variable
to the one you already have,
and you have a new
notion of residual,
which is what you explained
in the first round, what
you added in explanation
of the second round.
And then there's still something
left, and you keep on going.
If you let this thing
go for enough time,
you will have the
least squares solution.
At the end of the day, you
will have explained everything.
And each round, notice
that you might or not
decide to put the
variables back in, OK?
So you might have
that at each step
you have just one
variable, or you
might have that you
take multiple steps,
but you have fewer variables
than number of steps.
No matter what,
the number of steps
would be related to the
number of variables that
are active in your model, OK?
Does it makes sense?
This is the wordy version,
but now we go in details, OK?
But this is roughly
the speaking.
So first round, you try
to explain something,
then you see what's
left to explain.
And you keep the variables
that will explain the rest,
and then you need to write.
I'm not sure I used the
word, but it's important.
The key word here
is "sparsity," OK?
The fact that I'm
assuming my model
to depend on just
a few vectors--
sorry a few entries.
So it's a vector with
many zero entries.
Sparsity is the key word to
explain this property, which
is a property of the problem.
And so I build
algorithm that will
try to find sparse solution
explaining my data,
and this is one way.
So let's look at this list.
So you define the notion
of residual as this thing
that you want to try to
explain, and the first round
will be the output.
The second round will be
what's left to explain
after your prediction.
You have a coefficient
vector, OK,
because we're building
a linear function.
And then you have
an index set, which
is the set of variables which
are important at that stage.
So these are the three objects
that you have to initialize.
So at the first round,
the coefficient vector
is going to be 0.
The index set is
going to be empty.
And the residual
at the first round
is just going to be the
output, the output vector.
Then you find the
best single variable,
and then you update
the index set.
So you add that variable
to the index set.
To include such variables, you
compute the coefficient vector.
And then you update
the residual,
and then you start again, OK?
If you want, here I show
you the first exam--
just to give you an idea.
Suppose that this is--
so first of all,
notice this, OK?
Oh, it's so boring.
Forget about anything
that's written here.
Just look at this matrix.
The output vector is of the
same length of the column
of the matrix, right?
So each column of
the matrix will
be related to one variable.
So what you're going
to do is that you're
going to try to see
which of these best
explain my output
vector, and then
you're going to try to define
the residual and keep on going,
OK?
So in this case,
for example, you
can ask, which of the two
directions, X1 and X2,
best explain the vector Y, OK?
So this is the case
where it's simple.
I basically have
this one direction.
One variable is this one.
Another variable is this one.
And then I have that vector.
I want to know which
direction I should
pick to best explain my Y. Which
one do you think I should pick?
AUDIENCE: X1.
LORENZO ROSASCO:
I should pick X1?
OK.
This projection here will be
the weight I have to put to X1
to get a good prediction.
And then what's the residual?
Well, I have to take this X1.
I have to-- I have to take Yn.
I have to subtract that, and
this is what I have left.
So this is the simple terms, OK?
So that's what we want to do.
So we said it with hands.
We say it with words.
Here is, more or less,
the pseudocode, OK?
It's a bit boring to read.
You can see that it's
four lines of code anyway.
Now that we've said it
15 times, probably it
won't be that hard
to read because what
you see is that you have
a notion of residual.
You have the coefficient vector,
and you have the index set.
This is empty.
This is all 0's.
And this is the first round.
It's just the output.
Then what you do
is that you start.
And the free parameter here is
T, the number of iterations,
OK?
It's going to be
lambda, so to say.
What you do is--
OK, you have for each j--
so just notation.
j runs over the
variables, and capital Xj
will be the column of the
data matrix, the one that
corresponds to j's variable, OK?
And then what you
do in this line,
here I expand it, is to
find the coefficient--
sorry, find the error
that corresponds
to the best variable, OK?
If you look, it turns
out that it is--
if you assume-- oh, it
is equivalent to find
the column best
correlated with the output
is equivalent to find the
column that best explains
the output, or the residual.
These two things are the same.
So here, I write equivalence.
So pick the one
that you prefer, OK?
Either you say I find the
column that is best correlated
with the output or the
residual, or you find the column
that best explains the residual
in the sense of least squares,
OK?
These two things are equivalent.
Pick the one that you like.
And that's the
content of this one.
And then you select the
index of that column.
So you solve this
problem for each column.
It's an easy problem.
It's a one-dimensional problem.
And then you pick the
one column that you
like the most, which is
the one that gives you
the best correlation, a.k.a.
least square error.
Then you add this
k to the index set.
And then, in this
case, it's very simple.
I'm just going to--
I'm not going to
recompute anything.
So what I do is that
suppose that at--
you remember the
coefficient vector,
where it was all 0's, OK?
Then at the first round,
I compute one number,
the solution with, say, the
first coordinate, for example.
And then I add a number
in that entry, OK?
So this is the
orthonormal basis, OK?
So it has just all 0's,
but 1 in the position k.
So here I put this number.
This is just a typo.
And then what you do is
that you sum them up, OK?
So you have all 0's.
Just one number here, the first
iteration, then the other one.
And then you add this one there,
and you keep on going, OK?
This is the simplest
possible version.
And once you have this,
now you have this vector.
This is a long vector.
You multiply this--
sorry, this should be Xn.
Maybe we should take
note of the typos
because I'm never going
to remember all of them.
And then what you
do is that you just
discount what you explained
so far to the solution.
So you already explained
some part of the residual.
Now you discount this
new part, and you
define the new residual,
and then you go back.
This method is-- so
greedy approaches
is one name, as it often
happens in machine learning
and statistics and
other fields, things
get reinvented constantly, a
bit because people just come
to them from a
different perspective,
a bit because people just
decide studying and reading
is not priority sometimes.
And so this one algorithm
is often called greedy.
It's one example of
greedy approaches.
It's sometimes called
matching pursuit.
It's very much related to
so-called forward stagewise
regression.
That's how it's
called in statistics.
And well, it has a
bunch of other names.
Now, this one version is
just the basic version.
It's the simplex-- it's
the simplest version.
This step typically remains.
These two steps can be
changed slightly, OK?
For example, can you think
of another way of doing this?
Let me just give you a hint.
In this case, what you do is
that you select a variable.
You compute the coefficient.
Then you select
another variable.
You compute the coefficient
for the second variable,
but you keep the coefficient
you already computed
for the first variable.
They never knew that
you took another one
because you didn't take it yet.
So from this comment,
do you see how
you could change this method
to somewhat fix this aspect?
Do you see what I'm saying?
I would like to change
this one line where
I compute the coefficient
and this one line
even, perhaps, where I compute
the residual to account
for the fact that this method
basically never updated
the weights that
it computed before.
You only add a new one.
And this seems potentially
not a good idea,
because when you
have two variables,
it's better to compute the
solution with both of them.
So what could you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LORENZO ROSASCO: Right.
So what you could
do is essentially
what is called orthogonal
matching pursuit.
So you would take
this set, and now you
would solve a least
square problem
with the variables that
are in the index set up
to that point, all of them.
You recompute everything.
And now you have to solve not
a one-dimensional problem,
but n times k-dimensional
problem, where the k is the--
I don't know, k is a bad
name-- with the dimension
of the set that could
be T or more than T, OK?
And then at that point, you
also want to redefine this,
because you're not
discounting anymore
what you already explained,
but each time you're
recomputing everything.
So you just want to do Yn
minus the prediction, OK?
So this algorithm
is the one that
actually has better properties.
It works better.
You pay the price,
because each time
you have to recompute the
least squares solution.
And when you have more
than one variable inside,
then the problems
become big and big.
So if you stop after a few
iterations, it's great.
But if you start to have
many iterations each time,
you have to solve
a linear system.
So the complexity
is much higher.
This one here, as you can
imagine, is super fast.
So that's it.
So it turns out that this
method is, as I told you,
is called matching pursuit,
or if not matching pursuit,
forward stagewise regression,
is one way to approximate a zero
solution.
And one can prove
exactly in which sense
you can approximate it, OK?
So I think this is the
one that we might give you
this afternoon, right?
AUDIENCE: Orthogonal.
LORENZO ROSASCO: Oh, yeah,
the orthogonal version,
the nicer version.
The other way of doing this is
the one that basically says,
look, here what you're doing
is that you're just counting
the number of entries
different from 0's.
If you now were to replace
this with something that
does a bit more-- what it
does is it not only counts,
but it actually
sums up the weights.
So if you want, in one
case, you just check.
If a weight is bigger
than 0, you count it 1.
Otherwise, you count it 0.
Here you actually take
the absolute value.
So instead of summing
up binary values,
you sum up real numbers, OK?
This is what is
called the L1 norm.
So each weight doesn't
count for its sign,
but it actually counts
for each absolute value.
So it turns out that this one
term, which you can imagine--
the absolute value
looks like this, right,
and now you're just
summing them up.
So that thing is
actually convex.
So it turns out that you're
summing up two convex terms,
and the overall
functional is convex.
And if you want, you
can think of this a bit
as a relaxation
of the zero norm.
As we say, relaxation
in this sense
is the strict requirement.
So I talked about relaxation
before when I said instead
of binary values, it
takes real values,
and you optimize over the reals
instead of the binary values.
Here is kind of the same thing.
Instead of restricting yourself
to this functional, which
is binary-valued, now you
allow yourself to relax and get
real numbers.
And what you gain is
that this algorithm,
the corresponding optimization
problem is convex,
and you can try to solve it.
It is not still something
that we can do--
we cannot do what we did before.
We cannot just take derivatives
and set them equal to 0
because this term is not smooth.
The absolute value
looks like this,
which means that
here, around the kink,
is not differentiable.
But we can still
use convex analysis
to try to get the solution,
and actually the solution
doesn't look too complicated.
Getting there requires a
bit of convex analysis,
but there are techniques.
And the ones that
are trendy these days
are called forward-backward
splitting or proximal method
to solve this problem.
And apparently,
I'm not even going
to show them to you because
you don't even see them.
But essentially, it's
not too complicated.
Just to tell you in
one word what they do
is that they do the gradient
descent of the first term,
and then at each step of
the gradient they threshold.
So they take a step of the
gradient, get a vector,
look inside the vector.
If something is smaller than
a threshold that depends
on lambda, I set it equal to 0.
Otherwise, I let it go, OK?
So I didn't put it,
I don't know why,
because it's really
a one-line algorithm.
It's a bit harder to derive,
but it's very simple to check.
So let's talk one second
about this picture,
and then let me tell you about
what I'm not telling you.
So hiding behind
everything I said so far,
there is a linear system, right?
There is a linear system
that is n by p or d
or whatever you want to
call it, with the number
of p of variables.
And our game so far
has always been,
look, we have a linear system
that can be not invertible,
or even if it is, it might
have bad condition number,
and I want to try to find a
way to stabilize the problem.
The first round, we
basically replace the inverse
with an approximate inverse.
That's the classical
way of doing it.
Here, we're making
another assumption.
We're basically saying,
look, this vector,
it does look very long, so that
this problem seems ill-posed.
But in fact, if only a few
entries were different from 0
and if you were able to
tell me which one they are,
you can go in, delete
all these entries,
delete all the
corresponding columns,
and then you will have a matrix.
Now he looks short and large.
He will look skinny
and tall, OK?
And that probably would
be easier to solve.
It would be the case
where the problem is
one of the linear systema
that we know how to solve.
So what we described
so far is a way
to find solution of
linear systems that are--
with the number of equations
which is smaller than
the number of unknowns, and, by
definition, cannot be solved,
under the extra
assumption that, in fact,
there are fewer unknowns
than what it looks like.
It's just that I'm not telling
you which one they are, OK?
You see, if I
could tell you, you
would just get back to a
very easy problem, where
the number of unknowns
is much smaller, OK?
So this is a
mathematical effect, OK?
And the odds are open, because--
now they're not
because people have
been talking about this stuff
for 10 years constantly.
But one question is, how much
does this assumption buy you?
For example, could you prove
that in certain situations,
even if you don't know
the entry of this,
you could actually solve
this problem exactly?
So if I give them to you,
you can do it, right?
But is there a way to try
to guess them in some way
so that you can do almost as
good or with high probability
as well as if I tell
them in advance?
And it turned out that
the answer is yes, OK?
And the answer is basically that
if the number of entries that
are different from
0 is small enough
and the columns corresponding
to those variables
are not too correlated,
are not too collinear,
so they're
distinguishable enough
that when you
perturb the problem
a little bit nothing
changes, then
you can solve the
problem exactly, OK?
So this, on the one hand, is
exactly the kind of theory
that tells you why using greedy
methods and convex relaxation
will give you a good
approximation to L0,
because that's basically
what this story tells you.
People have been using this--
and so this is interesting
for us-- people have been using
this observation in a slightly
different context, which
is the context where--
you see, for us, Y and
X, we don't choose.
We get.
And whatever they are, they are.
And if it's correlate-- if
the columns are nice, nice.
But if they're not nice, sorry,
you have to live with it, OK?
But there are settings where
you can think of the following.
Suppose that you have
a signal, and you want
to be able to reconstruct it.
So the classical Shannon
sampling theorem results
basically tell you
that, I don't know,
if you have something
which has been limited,
you have to sample twice
the maximum frequency.
But this is kind of
worst case because it's
assuming that all the bands,
all the frequencies, are full.
Suppose that now we play--
it's an analogy, OK?
But I tell you, oh,
look, it's true,
the maximum frequency of this.
But there's only another
frequency, this one.
Do you really need to
sample that much, or you
can do much less?
And so it turns out that
basically the story here,
as you're answering
this question,
it turns out that, yes,
you can do much less.
Ideally, what you would
like to say, well,
instead of being twice
the maximum frequency,
if I have just four
frequencies different from 0,
I'd have to do
eight samples, OK?
That would be ideal,
but you would have
to know which one they are.
You don't, so you pay a price,
but it's just logarithmic.
So you basically say
that you can almost--
you have a new sampling
theorem that tells you
that you don't need
to sample that much.
You don't need to sample
that low either, which
would be, say, the
maximum frequency is d.
The number of non-zero
frequencies is s.
So with classical, you
would have to say 2d.
Ideally, we would
like to say 2s.
Actually, what you can say
is something like 2s log d.
So you have a log d price
that you pay because you
didn't know where they are.
But still, it's much less than
being linear in the dimension.
So essentially, the field
of compressed sensing
has been built around
this observation,
and the focus is
slightly different.
Instead of saying I want to do
a statistical estimation where
I can just build this, what
you do is say I have a signal.
And now I view this
as a sensing matrix
that I design with
the property that I
know will allow me to
do this estimation well.
And so you basically assume that
you can choose those vectors
in certain ways,
and then you can
prove that you can reconstruct
with much fewer samples, OK?
And this has been
used, for example--
I never remember for, as
you call in MEG-- in what?
No, MRI, MRI.
Two things I didn't
tell you about,
but it's worth
mentioning are, suppose
that what I tell
you is actually it's
not individual entries that are
0, but group of entries that
are 0, for example, because each
entry is a biological process.
So I have genes, but
genes are actually
involved in biological process.
So there is a group of genes
that is doing something.
I have a group of genes
that are doing something,
and I want to select is not
individual genes, but groups.
Can you twist this stuff in such
a way that you select groups?
Yes.
What if the groups are
actually overlapping?
How do you want to
deal with the overlaps?
Do you want to keep the overlap?
Do you want to cut the overlap?
What if you have a
tree structure, OK?
What do you do with this?
So first of all, who
gives it information, OK?
And then if you have the
information, how do you use it,
and how are you going to use it?
See, this is the whole
field of structure sparsity.
It's the whole industry
of building penalties
other than L1 that would
allow you to incorporate
this kind of prior information.
And if you want as the
place, as in kernel methods,
the kernel was the
place where you could
incorporate prior information.
This is the case
where, in this field,
you can do that by designing
a suitable regularizer.
And then a lot of
the reason is this.
So here we'll translate
with these new regularizers.
The last bit is that, with
a bit of a twist, some
of the idea that I show
you now that are basically
related to vectors
and sparsity translate
to more general context, in
particular that of matrices
that have low rank, OK?
The classical example is
suppose that I give you--
it's matrix completion, OK?
I give you a matrix,
but I actually
delete most of the
entries of the matrix.
And I tell you, OK, estimate
the original matrix.
Well, how can I do that, right?
Well, it turns out that
if the matrix itself
had very low rank, so that many
of the columns and rows you saw
were actually related
to each other,
you might actually
be able to do that.
And the way you chose the
entries to delete or select
was not malicious,
then you would
be able to fill in the
missing entries, OK?
And the theory
behind this is very
similar to the
theory that allows
to fill in the right
entries of the vector, OK?
Last bit-- PCA in 15 minutes.
So what we've seen so far
was a very hard problem
of variable selection.
It is still a
supervised problem,
where I give you labels, OK?
The last bit I
want to show you is
PCA, which is the case where
I don't give you labels.
And what you try to answer
is actually-- perhaps
it's like the simpler question.
Because you don't want to
select one of the directions,
but you would like
to know if there
are directions that matter.
So you allow
yourself, for example,
to combine the different
directions in your data, OK?
So this question is interesting
for many, many reasons.
One is data visualization,
for example.
You have stuff that you cannot
look at because you have,
for example, digits in
very high dimensions.
You would like to look at them.
How do you do it?
Well, you like to
find directions.
The first direction
to project everything,
the second direction, three
direction, because then you
can plot and look at them, OK?
And this is one visualization
of these images here.
And I'll remember
now the code now.
It's written here.
You have different
colors, and what you see
is that this actually
did a good job.
Because what you expect is that
if you do a nice visualization,
what you would like to have
is that similar numbers
or same numbers are
in the same regions,
and perhaps similar
numbers are close, OK?
So this is one reason
why you want to do this.
One reason why you
might want to do this
is also because you
might want to reduce
the dimensionality of your
data just to compress them
or because you might hope that
certain dimensions don't matter
or are simply noise.
And so you just want
to get rid of that
because this could be good
for statistical reasons.
OK, so the game is going
to be the following.
X is the data space,
which is going to be RD.
And we want to define a map M
that sends vectors of length D
into vectors of length k.
So k is going to be my
reduced dimensionality.
And what we're going
to do is that we're
going to build a basic method
to do this, which is PCA,
and we're going to give a purely
geometric view of PCA, OK?
And this is going
to be done by taking
first the case where k is equal
to 1 and then iterate to go up.
So at the first
case, we're going
to ask, if I give you vectors
which are D dimensional,
how can I project them in
one dimension with respect
to some criterion
of optimality, OK?
And here what we ask is, we want
to project the data in the one
dimension that would give
me the best possible error.
So I think I had it before.
Do I have it-- no, no.
This was done for another
reason, but it's useful now.
If you have this
vector and you want
to project in this direction,
and this is a unit vector,
what do you do?
I want to know how to write this
vector here, the projection.
What you do is that you take the
inner product between Yn and X.
You get the number, and that
number is the length you
want to assign to X1, OK?
So suppose that w
is the direction.
And I have a vector
x, and I want
to give the projection, OK?
What do I do?
I take the inner
product of x and w,
and this is the length I have
to assign to the vector w, which
is unit norm, OK?
So this is the
best approximation
of xi in the direction of w.
Does it make sense?
I fix a w, and I want to know
how well I can describe x.
I project x in that
direction, and then I
take the difference between
x and the projection, OK?
And then what I do is that
I sum over all points.
And then I check, among
all possible directions,
the one that give
me the best error.
So suppose that
is your data set.
Which direction
you think is going
to give me the best error?
AUDIENCE: Keep going.
LORENZO ROSASCO: Well, if
you go in this direction,
you can explain most
of the stuff, OK?
You can reconstruct it best.
So this is going
to be the solution.
So the question here is really,
how do you solve this problem?
You could try to minimize
with respect to w.
But in fact, it's not clear what
kind of computation you have.
And if we massage
this a little bit,
it turns out that it is actually
exactly an eigenvalue problem.
So that's what we
want to do next.
So conceptually, what we want
to do is what I said here
and nothing more.
I want to find the single
individual direction that
allows me to reconstruct best,
on average, all the training
set points.
And now what we want
to do is just to check
what kind of computation
these entail and learn
a bit more about this, OK?
So this notation is just to
say that the vector is norm 1
so that I don't have to fumble
with the size of the vector.
OK, so let's do a
couple of computations.
This is ideal after lunch.
So you just take this
square and develop it, OK?
And remember that
w is unit norm.
So when you do w
transpose w, you get 1.
And then if you--
and if you don't forget
to put your square
and if you just
develop this, you'll
see that this is
an equality, OK?
There is a square missing here.
So you have xi square.
Then you would have
the product of xi
and this, which will be
w transpose xi square.
And then you would
also have this square,
but this square is w transpose
xi and then w transpose w,
which is 1.
And so what you see is
that this would create--
instead of three terms
we have two because two
cancel out-- not cancel out.
They balance each other.
OK.
So then I'd argue that if
instead of minimizing this,
because this is equal to this,
you can maximize this.
Why?
Well, because this
is just a constant.
It doesn't depend
on w at all, so I
can drop it from my functional.
The solution, the minimum,
the minimum will be different,
but the minimizer, the w
that solves the problem,
will be the same, OK?
And then here is
minimizing something
with a minus, which is the same
as maximizing the same thing
without the minus, OK?
I don't ask, so far, so
good, because I'm scared.
So what you see now
is that basically
if the data were centered,
basically this would just
be a variance.
If the data are centered,
so there is a minus 0 here,
maybe you can interpret this
as measuring the variance
in one direction.
And so you have
another interpretation
of PCA, which is the one
where instead of picking
the single direction with the
best possible reconstruction,
you're picking the direction
where the variance of the data
is bigger, OK?
And these two points of view
are completely equivalent.
Essentially, whenever
you have a square norm,
thinking about
maximizing the variance
or minimizing the
reconstruction are two
complementary dual ideas, OK?
So that's what you
will be doing here.
One more bit.
What about computation?
So this is-- so we can
think about reconstruction.
You can think about
variance, if you like.
What about this computation?
What kind of
computation is this, OK?
If we massage it
a little bit, we
see that is just an
eigenvalue problem.
So this is how you do it.
This actually look-- so it's
annoying, but it's very simple.
So I wrote all the passages.
This is a square, so it's
something times itself.
This whole thing is
symmetric, so you
can swap the order of
this multiplication.
So you get w transpose
xi, xi transpose w.
But then this is
just the sum that was
going to involve these terms.
So I can let the sum enter,
and this is what you get.
So you get w transpose
1/n xi xi transpose w.
So this is just a number. w
transpose xi is just a number.
But the moment you look at
something that looks like xi,
xi transpose, what is that?
Well, just look at
dimensionality, OK?
1 times d times d times 1 gives
you a number, which is 1 by 1.
Now you're doing the
other way around.
So what is this?
AUDIENCE: It's a matrix.
LORENZO ROSASCO: It's a--
AUDIENCE: Matrix.
LORENZO ROSASCO: It's a matrix.
And it's a matrix which is d
by d, and it's of rank 1, OK?
And what you do now is
that you sum them all up,
and what you have is
that this quantity here
becomes what is called
the quadratic form.
It is a matrix C, which
just looks like this.
And it's squeezed in between
two vectors, w transpose and w.
So now what you want
to do is that you
can rewrite this just this
way as maximizing the w--
sorry, finding the
unit norm vector w that
maximizes this quadratic form.
And at this point,
you can still ask me
who cares, because
it's just keeping
on rewriting the same problem.
But it turns out that
essentially using
Lagrange theorem, it is
relatively simple to do,
you can check that--
oh, so boring-- that the
solution of this problem
is the maximum eigenvector
of this matrix, OK?
So this you can
leave as an exercise.
Essentially, you take the
Lagrangian of this and use
a little bit of duality, and
you show that the [INAUDIBLE]
of this problem is just
the maximum eigen--
so the eigenvalues-- ugh,
the eigenvector corresponding
to the maximum eigenvalue
of the matrix C.
So finding this
direction is just
solving an eigenvalue problem.
OK.
I think just do last few of
those slide, kind of cute.
It's pretty simple, OK?
So the one part,
this line after lunch
is a bit there for
because I'm nice.
But really, the only one part
which is a bit more complicated
is this one here.
The rest is really just
very simple algebra.
So what about k equal 2?
I run out of time.
But it turns out that
what you want to do
is basically if you say that
you want to look for a second--
so you look at the
first direction.
You solve it, and you know that
it's the first eigenvector--
the first eigenvector.
And then let's say that
you add the constraint
that the second
direction you find
has to be orthogonal
to the first direction.
You might not want
to do this, OK?
But if you do, if
you say you add
the orthogonality constraint,
then what you can check
is that you can repeat--
sorry, I didn't do it.
It's on my note, the one
that I have on the website,
and the computation
is kind of cute.
And what you see is that
the solution of this problem
looks exactly like
the one before,
only with this
additional constraint,
is exactly the
eigenvector corresponding
to the second largest
eigenvalue, OK?
And so you can keep on going.
And so now this
gives you a way to go
from k equal to 1
to k bigger than 1,
and you can keep on going, OK?
So if you're looking
for the direction that
maximizes the variance
or the reconstruction,
they turn out to be
the biggest eigen--
the vectors-- ugh, the
eigenvectors corresponding
to the biggest eigenvalues of
this matrix C, which what you
can call it as a second
moment or covariance
matrix of the data.
OK, so this is more
or less the end.
This is the basic, basic,
basic version of this.
You can mix this with pretty
much all the other stuff
we said today.
So one is, how about trying to
use kernels to do a nonlinear
extension of this?
So here we just looked at
the linear reconstruction.
How about nonlinear
reconstruction?
So what you would do
is that you would first
map the data in
some way and then
try to find some kind of
nonlinear dimensionality
reduction.
You see that what I'm
doing here is that I'm just
using this linear--
it's just a linear
dimensionality reduction, just
a linear operator.
But what about
something nonlinear?
What if my data lie on
some kind of structure
that looked like that--
our beloved machine
learning Swiss roll.
Well, if you do
PCA, well, you're
just going to find a plane that
cuts that thing somewhere, OK?
But if you try to embed the
data in some nonlinear way,
you could try to resolve this.
And this has been
much of the research
done in the direction
of manifold learning.
Here there are just
a few keywords--
kernel PCA is the easiest
version, Laplacian map,
eigenmaps, diffusion
maps, and so on, OK?
I only touch quickly
upon random projection.
There is a whole
literature about those.
The idea is, again, that
by multiplying the data
by random vectors, you can keep
the information in the data
and might be able
to reconstruct them
as well as to
preserve distances.
Also, you can combine ideas from
sparsity with ideas from PCA.
For example, you can say, what
if I want to know not only--
I want to find something
like an eigenvector,
but I would like the entries
of the eigenvector to be 0.
So can I add here a
constraint which basically
says, among all
the unit vectors,
find the one whose
entries are most--
so I want to add an
L0 norm or L1 norm.
So how can you do that, OK?
And this leads to sparse PCA
and other structured matrix
estimation problems, OK?
So this is, again, something
I'm not going to tell you about,
but that's kind
of the beginning.
And this, more or less, brings
us to the desert island,
and I'm done.